at least you as voters wanted to make
clear that Donald Trump is not welcome
in Minneapolis and should be removed
from office if he's just not fit to be
president of his country
he's flagrantly abusing his powers and
he needs to be stopped while these
voters waited for hours in the rain to
watch Trump take the stage in the Target
Center arena unshaken in their support
for him despite the impeachment inquiry
I think it's all made up I think it's
fake news and I think it's just another
way to try to get the amount of office I
have faith that it's gonna work out to
Trump's advantage it's gonna be another
black eye for the Democrats that just
keep doing nothing to try to get him out
as the impeachment inquiry gains more
and more support among the general
public the president's diehard
supporters react with anger and defiance
Donald Trump's reelection campaign wants
to use this event here in Minneapolis to
rally his base around him the president
however seems more and more consumed by
the impeachment proceedings at a
combative campaign rally and angry
Donald Trump lashed out against the
Democrats accusing them of trying to
overturn the 2016 election because they
know they cannot beat him in 2020 they
want to erase your vote like it never
existed they want to erase your voice
and they want to erase your future
the president fired off insults at
journalists and lawmakers using
profanity to attack his political
opponents in particular former Vice
President Joe Biden he was only a good
vice president because he understood how
to kiss Barack Obama's under fire from
his own party for pulling US troops out
of northern Syria Trump defended his
decision we were supposed to be in Syria
for 30 days we've now been there for 10
years we were supposed to be in
Afghanistan for a short period of time
we're now going to be there for close to
19 years it's time to bring him home his
speech was interrupted by some
protesters who however were quickly
removed from the arena
I am energized the president told the
crowd and his supporters thanked him
with applause and cheerful chants but
outside the arena the anti-trump protest
carried on late into the night